a tubal ligation procedure is a
permanent method of birth control where
the surgeon
cuts or seals off the fallopian tubes in
order to prevent pregnancy a woman's
reproductive system includes the vagina
the canal where sperm are deposited and
babies emerge during delivery uterus the
pear-shaped organ where a fertilized egg
grows into a baby fallopian tubes two
ducts that transport eggs from the
ovaries to the uterus and where sperm
usually fertilize eggs and ovaries two
glands that produce and release eggs
during sexual intercourse sperm from the
male are introduced into the vagina they
travel through a channel called the
cervix and into the uterus the sperm
then move into the fallopian tubes where
they can meet and fertilize eggs that
have been released from the ovaries
pregnancy begins with a fertilized egg
if you don't want to become pregnant you
may choose a birth control method from
one of several categories abstinence
contraception or sterilization to
permanently avoid pregnancy by having a
medical procedure tubal ligation is one
form of sterilization before the
procedure begins an intravenous line
will be started and you will be offered
medication to help you relax
local anesthesia will be applied to numb
the area of the operation and you will
remain awake for its duration in some
cases general or spinal anesthesia may
be used instead
if you are having a laparoscopic tubal
ligation your doctor will begin by
making a tiny incision near your belly
button and another just above your pubic
bone
your doctor will then inject carbon
dioxide a harmless gas through a tube
inserted into the upper incision the
carbon dioxide inflates your abdominal
cavity allowing your doctor to clearly
see and work around your internal organs
next your doctor will introduce a
lighted instrument called a laparoscope
through one of the incisions the
laparoscope projects images of the
structures inside your abdomen onto a
monitor through the other incision your
doctor will pass surgical instruments to
grasp your fallopian tubes and close
them off using the cutting and tying
blocking
or sealing technique at the end of the
procedure your doctor will allow the
carbon dioxide to escape and close the
incisions with dissolving stitches if
you are having a mini laparotomy tubal
ligation your doctor will make a small
incision just above your pubic bone he
or she will grasp the fallopian tubes
with forceps
and close them off using one of several
techniques at the end of the procedure
the incision will be closed with
stitches this method is often used just
after childbirth
Murata me your doctor will make a two to
five inch incision in your lower abdomen
he or she will locate the fallopian
tubes and close them off using one of
several techniques at the end of the
procedure the incision will be closed
with stitches immediately afterward you
will be taken to the recovery area if
you have a laparoscopic tubal ligation
you will likely go home the same day if
you have a laparotomy or a mini
laparotomy after childbirth your
hospital stay may be extended slightly